he is emerging as one of england's most
inspirational managers leading the
national team to places
it's not been for decades his best
friend
andy woodman is not surprised by the
success
the pair still speak daily they first
met
age 15 as apprentices at crystal palace
and were best man at each other's
weddings and even back then
gareth southgate had an intellectual
approach to the game
i've gone around europe and around the
world watching how teams
develop and evolve and how other sports
work together and so he's taking a very
academic approach to it
unbelievably academic people have no
idea of the
the the sort of hard yards garrosh put
in to study
to study learn and and that's that scarf
those closest to him also say that
having played at the highest level
himself
he knows what's gone wrong in the past
he was always a sensible one in that 96
squad but that wasn't hard if i'm honest
putting his way he wasn't in a dentist
chair he was one of the players that
would
stay behind and and was pretty sensible
i think that's why he's done so well
with his squad
thank you miss the pressure of failure
and national humiliation the miss
penalty at 96
which saw him poke fun at himself in
this advert for pizza
have also given him a level of empathy
that many managers
have not developed this time is it the
post
that humility is something people in the
town of harrogate
near where he lives recognize clearly
just a lovely feeling knowing that you
know something so close to home
and everyone's so proud to be english
and been playing for the
for their team any shops down there for
you all is
closed so they say they have a little
poster in the window saying
gary's shops here does come into their
shoes and have a fat rascal
[Applause]
sports psychologists say being able to
connect with people
has given gareth southgate a massive
edge in moulding
a national team that's often been riven
by rivalries
and fear of the last 15 years i've known
him
trust understanding and building
relationships that's what he's
as we're seeing brilliant he's very good
at football and he's a ruthless
competitor but in terms of building
trust understanding people and building
relationships
that's why i think he's such a brilliant
leader
there's no doubting southgate still has
an enormous challenge ahead he's not won
anything yet
but how he's evolved from player to
manager
will hopefully give england everything
they need to bring
football home alex rossi sky news
bromley